NARRATOR: Today, we're
showcasing all the engineering
design that our seniors
have been doing.
So it's a yearlong project,
where a lot of the majors
interact with other
engineering majors,
so you'll have mechanical,
aerospace, electrical, civil,
mining engineers all
working on one project.
And today's the day that we're
showing everybody what we've
been working on the whole year.
All the seniors in engineering
have been putting together
projects that have been funded
by industry professionals, so
my professional's Honeywell.
And they work in industry
building your aircraft engines
and stuff like that, so
it's a great opportunity
for seniors to get immersed
before they graduate and work
on real life projects.
NARRATOR: I think the best
thing about this project
is that for so long we've
been working in class,
working on mathematics,
working on theory,
and this project actually allows
us to apply in a high level way
the things that
we've been learning
to see the real world
applications of the engineering
concepts.
My passion's
aerospace engineering.
And so being able to
talk about a project
that I've worked
on in that field
is just a lot of fun for me.
I like being able to share
some of that information
with people who think
our project's cool
and talking to people who
are younger engineering
students, who maybe want to get
involved with some of the stuff
that we're working on.
I think that's my
favorite part is just
kind of sharing what we've
done with other people.